sexy horses adorable children beautiful
pastures what do these all have in
common
calendars the Tri guys are making a 2018
holiday calendar no matter what's going
on in your life there's like something
you're looking forward to the slow but
steady march towards death's door you
can put that on your calendar I'm very
excited to be in a sexy pinup style
calendar today I assume that's what
we're doing we're gonna be listing every
single holiday you could possibly care
about on this calendar you'll be able to
buy it each of the photos is gonna be
four of us posing and representing
multiple holidays the rest of the
background and some of the props will be
illustrated by professional artist no
make sure it's a little sexy January
time for drinking and New Year's
resolutions to not drink as much what
better way to start the year with barely
remembering how you started it we're
opposed in a fictional world like models
for New Year's you wear suits you were
sparkling gowns pretend you're on like a
cover of Vogue and then we're gonna pose
in a realistic world like drunk people
I've had way too much so we'll see which
one ends up in the count it's the month
where you say this year I'm gonna be
better than I was last year I've never
worn a top hat who wears
I got to make out with someone at
midnight why do you not having reference
company where I'm fighting nothing
matters first thing you open to this
counting blood damn does it meet some
fireworks in the background this gonna
be all illustrating now all of you got
shrunk down by a wizard and you're
holding giant chopsticks and he got to
pick up dumplings that's funny is better
I hated Valentine's Day and then I fell
in love me and my wife we've gone to
like Michigan cute cabin we've gone to
like a cute cabin in Wisconsin
basically anyway there's cute cabin
wolves booked it around Valentine's Day
I just got you a Christmas gift and now
I got to come up with something else
February it's also a lot of way more
important things like Black History
Month and Lunar New Year's midni are
gonna be holding a dragon what's this
dragon working with if we're gonna have
a very ornate tale okay so she fancies
all right actually took an independent
study on puppetry but I never got to pop
it a giant dragon so this is the day I
will be writing on top of that dress you
like a [ __ ] Studio Ghibli movie
character I love this I'm ecstatic that
we are celebrating Lunar New Year as
opposed to Valentine's Day which would
be a photo of me eating a link cuisine
alone in the corner think about all the
fun times you have last weekend with
your wife I'm 3/32 Irish so I love Saint
Patrick's Day
it's just an excuse for people to get
wasted why are you not at work it's a
Tuesday we're thrilled to have you in a
try guys video yes what are we doing
great questions also National Women's
Month so for the photo we're having lady
like play us and Devin is gonna be
myself
notice important thing to remember is
that you're the best
how are you I'm Keith she's gonna have
to wear some squares to really capture
the true essence of having jen represent
me because we're both cuties also she's
clumsiest [ __ ] it's gonna be all good
let's rock that like fine line between
hipster boy and lesbian chic I love to
be I don't your Jen complain enough you
ask them to turn down the thermostat but
no one seems to be listening to you yeah
Kristen is playing me because she has a
husband how often do you I can talk
about your husband
too much say my husband more I will get
a little a girl is a Jaguar suck the
Jaguars do not suck hi my name is Eugene
and I'm here to slay I think we're both
really chill both cool but also
confident I'm sure you have amazing
beautiful talented intelligent I do I
have the other try guys
okay like Freddie Eugene more than
Eugene yeah Kristen Jenn and Devon we
should be completely indistinguishable
from one another go back to breathing in
my ears guys that made me really
uncomfortable
yes Freddie don't pay attention totally
disengaged nasmyth Eugene yeah yeah yeah
he doesn't like it
anyway this makes me realize guys I'm
sorry I do that to y'all bars no you're
not I'm sorry that we let you to April
is Easter I always thought the Easter
Bunny was amazing so for the photo
Keith's gonna be a giant Easter Bunny
and we're all gonna be like little
flowers you guys this outfit is totally
inappropriate where is my diaper it's
spring time I get to finally live out my
dream of being a naked baby in a
flowerpot thinks he's gonna be the best
sunflower Wow
you were so good no way you're gonna
beat this look at this
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
easter is very special to me because
Easter was when I proposed and then I
had one egg impossibly so she would find
it last and then it made us both be
kneeling hey you won't get married and
she was like yes we had also discussed
it prior nothing happens in May couldn't
tell you Mother's Day is in May it's
also National Pet week we're actually
gonna bring in live animals to hold in
the photo this is gonna be difficult if
she bites uh-huh
just take it just take cuz if you flail
your hand you could kill her how fun you
may have seen that I got a puppy
recently that is true does not make me a
dog person
cats are still better I'm gonna be
posing with a tiny little bunny rabbit
toy and cuteness and [ __ ] I'm kinda
like a bird big awkward loud can I bring
my arm and closer I wouldn't recommend
it okay then I will not I know a lot
about this cat rice balls a munchkin cat
just means that she's funny-looking hee
hee which means he's funny-looking does
empanada have a lot of sex Oh feel bad
for asking yeah look at that
we're gonna do paintings of our mothers
that are illustrated behind us I think
my porch where my mom is from my wedding
my mom loves to read Becky my work now
also reads like crazy so maybe I have a
huge Oedipus complex luckily my mom my
mom's family is Italian so whenever we
would do a holiday meal she always makes
sure to get like the good stuff
I was imported from Italy and that was
her way of making sure that everyone had
a good time the holidays I really think
that she is the strongest person I've
ever met in my life
she had breast cancer when I was in high
school and she kicked us to Hess
she sent me and my sister away for the
first couple weeks of her chemo it was
really important that we saw her strong
and never weak [ __ ] respect your mom
don't be a little dick because I know
all of you out there little shits to
your mom's especially if you're hitting
puberty and you're the worst that gonna
test was most important in your life you
know happy that happy day that was
beauty June is Pride Month I'm proud to
be LGBT the other guys aren't even
though ever things keeping Zach I have a
lot of LGBT friends and family members
and it's a really great time to show
support to people we care about Jude
[Music]
every good calendar needs one mid-air
jump shot a little lower
right on right lower kick something all
of these are gonna be single color flags
that will connect to the rainbow
background look at these americaís socks
what could possibly top dude oh wait
July so for the fourth of July we're
gonna be doing what everybody does
having a cookout baby
you see your pants we don't even know if
you're wearing any this is so hot
Ned of course is the grill master
because Ned loves that [ __ ] so I'm gonna
be representing the thing that I love
most protecting my skin from the
dangerous Sun America I'm the least sexy
in this photo what's going on so there
was actually one July in my life where I
competed in a hot dog eating competition
yeah great job now
I ate ten hot dogs and then I threw up
into a lake we're gonna be outside
grilling high-fiving our neighbors
drinking cheap beers that's what
Americans do I love protection you're
like the most excited about sports
you're looking at the fireworks
yeah
I got a so this is the most skin you're
getting this calendar no six no six
seeking lot of months in August is
back-to-school it's when all the kids
are [ __ ] bombed and all the parents
are thrilled we are recreating a
fictional portrait of us as classmates
in elementary school we never got to
hang out as five-year-olds give me your
stuff you know I always got excited for
back-to-school it's a dragon beating my
my stepdad get to go shopping it to pick
out like your new notebook all your new
binders planner that you'll never write
him ever I loved school as a kid I think
we've all been friends cuz we were all
kind of losers message as Scoobies as I
am now I was even goofier as a
five-year-old that sort of big bombastic
huge smile it's been around forever I
could see the try guys as friends as
kids stop hey don't throw it it can't
see us as friends now that one makes
less sense to me Oh from check yes but
circles no my yarmulke thank you you're
finally gonna be a man we're not gonna
go through twelve months without
representing my tribe we put some Jews
up in this [ __ ] it's Rosh Hashanah and
Yom Kippur
here's your Jewish horn this is called
the shofar you blow this to celebrate
New Year's I dropped out of Hebrew
school so please do not take anything I
say at face value and since zach has
never had his Bar Mitzvah we're finally
making him study the Torah while all of
us have a great time outside in the
leaves yeah
I have three anniversaries with my wife
our wedding anniversary
exactly thank you anniversary I'm coming
gage that's in September and then the
anniversary of when we started dating we
have a date night every week so you need
some reason to celebrate sometimes for
me my family we always use it as a time
of self-reflection and for
self-betterment a sofa cool are you my
daddy spoopy Mon it's Halloween the
month where ghouls and demons crawl the
earth cobwebs go on begging strangers
for candy pumpkin spice I'm most excited
for this month because we finally get
into some heavy prosthetics makeup and
custom a monster transformation we're
gonna be for classic monsters I'm going
to be the sexiest try guy I'm gonna be a
zombie Oh in the face when I died Eugene
will be a vampire because he sucks the
life out of everyone he means yes this
is a very sick see mommies are always
datoria Slee lookin for their wives who
got buried in a different to me they're
just like my wife and Zach will be
adding just a little bit to his body
here to become a werewolf Wow
oh my god I'm the hairy beast I was born
to be what's wrong nothing you look very
sexy didn't have enough wrap to wrap my
legs so we're gonna do it in two parts
zombie mummy needs fans can you give
them a hand
I do not eat expired food
rude werewolf werewolf werewolf
oh stop licking your balls werewolf oh
well these fake teeth are very intrusive
I'm Charlie scary I've been sitting on
that joke for 3,000 years
hey okay during the heat you don't want
to decompose both like your body I'll
hold this bot all right
for this November photo we're a family
finally before you start ruining things
let's smile I have so many feelings
about November I remember my first
Thanksgiving my mom tried to make a
turkey but instead she just gave up and
made bulgogi we tried really hard to fit
in it's like the time where you sit down
with your family you make a big dinner
you eat way too much food and you feel
bloated afterwards so for Thanksgiving
we are creating a family portrait the
classic 1950s Thanksgiving dinner all
hiding their inner turmoil pretending to
be happy I'll be carving that bird so
hot Zach will be sort of playing the
maternal role do you guys say I'm the
mama y'all drink from a teat our two
kids
Eugenia Ned do you love me mummy it's
gonna be sweet it's gonna be family the
dad's carving the turkey and the mom is
passing the peas and the kids are like
on their phones not paying attention
because 2017 and no one understands
family anymore
[Music]
presenting your family it's Thanksgiving
happy holidays there's so many holidays
in December I just love that everybody
has something to celebrate
and of course sexy Santa I mean we're at
the last month at this point I don't
feel like I've really had the
opportunity to sexy we are all opening
presents in our pajamas on Christmas
morning or for Zach one of the eight
morning's what would you like to spin
the dreidel well yeah yeah go for it
Wow gimel that's 3 kisses when the snow
falls it's just like a magical landscape
I love winter I love everything I just
you know what I love life happy holidays
in December I got to unwrap the best
present of all myself
[Music]
if Keith is gonna be sexy I feel like we
should all be we weren't just shooting
this for fun you can actually buy this
calendar in real life happy 2018 go to
shop at BuzzFeed calm calm calm you
should get this calendar it's gonna be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sign us up zombie no we'll see Rockstar
stay stay
[ __ ] some he really nailed it in the
coffin
[Applause]